[Music]
it must
it must be long
Wow you're looking cozy today yeah well
I like to hang out in here sometimes
because it's it's warmer than the
cabinet so where's your partner
butter oh we're not always together oh I
faked fun I went to a potluck or a
cookie party is that a thing I'll just
text and ask
oh I haven't texted back yet baby
buddy's been in the bathroom for an hour
oh well butters lactose intolerant it's
very common in Ashkenazi Jews so yeah it
could be hours before we see them again
yeah but don't people usually take their
phones with them if they're gonna be in
the bathroom for a long time
this is cool I'm uncool independent
toasty coming through here
[Music]
toast good thing you called your bit of
F because this is [ __ ] up it's been
two hours if my boot McCollum doesn't
text me back within five he's toast
sorry you know what I'm in it really
don't ride a toy term I'm sorry before
you did it it's awkward okay what
letters harder something more like
butter felt and I'm sewage somewhere
I mean butter is just so slippery what
if butters was someone else like some
pop-tart or muffin or bagel oMG but it
was tagged on insta at the mall ten
minutes ago
what is that a dog wait don't
dogs eat butter don't dogs eat bunny
ah peanut butter no but I get a hold of
yourself don't do it don't text them and
I just oh boy a little full set now like
a small village eat like it easygoing
emoji like the penguin it's super casual
it'll be super you can't text them
anymore I'm not letting you what's all
this I'm breaking up with butter wait
it's only been three hours
don't you think you two might be
overreacting like don't think I'm
overreacting how dare you belittle my
bit of us feelings and their time of
need
it's okay
don't cry oh gosh check your whole other
social media accounts
I'm checking Twitter I check it hashtag
butters dead letters and oh my god
hashtag
butters dead haven't seen anything yet
but if butters not dead has butter
texted you back yet
no butters definitely a hundred percent
dead sad sorry tears wait dead that
seems like a pretty crazy conclusion I
[Music]
can't believe butter is dead in a ditch
somewhere probably happy in my raccoon
or Paula Deen
they're running ramping up feed toasties
hang in there I'll call and check on you
in the morning
[Applause]
[Music]
hey babe sorry I'm so late my phone died
oh you're not here at night didn't even
notice
hey toes what was there an Amber Alert
about myself
it must feel
[Music]
it seems
love she has for me